[Music]
on this saturday night
the rush to get astrazeneca into arms
the shots set to expire with all the
changes
it's difficult to manage and health
canada's new protocol
surrounding the vaccine the rise of the
variant in britain
putting the uk's reopening plan in
jeopardy
accusations of a toxic culture at
canada's royal military college
plus the virtual visit the future of
telemedicine
in canada
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us tens of thousands of vaccine doses
have been given a new lease on life
health canada is extending the expiry
date on about 45 000 doses
of the astrazeneca vaccine they were set
to expire on monday but they can now be
used until canada day
that's good news in many parts of the
country including ontario
as michael couture explains health care
workers there have been rushing to get
shots into arms
to avoid any waste
cars lined up onto the street at this
drive-through vaccination clinic near
kingston ontario
staff hoping to hand out as many
astrazeneca doses as possible
before they were expected to expire
monday
i've never seen people so excited to get
vaccines
they're very jovial very very happy
then by midday the doses that may have
been otherwise wasted
were given a new lease on life by health
canada the
vaccine indeed can extend for a month to
july 1st
which i think is welcome news in terms
of being able to
make sure there's no wastage the ontario
pharmacists association knows the sudden
change could lead to more questions
about the vaccine
and even vaccine hesitancy but they
point out people can also wait until the
12-week mark
for their second dose something
ontarians don't seem to want to wait for
is kids returning to school the
provincial science table is recommending
a reopening of schools in regions where
it's deemed safe
if they are open i'm totally willing to
let them go back to school if they want
infectious disease experts point out
kids aren't likely to transmit covet 19
to
adults and the mental health impacts of
not being in school
are significant for students not just to
impact them
during this short period but also
lifelong and then
their kids like to me
when you factor all these things there's
there's no question on what the right
step is
friday montreal took a step towards a
post-pandemic life
it was the first night in months that
quebecers didn't have a curfew
businesses were busy it clearly caused
some to let their guard down
even montreal's mayor valerie plant was
seen in a photo posted on social media
breaking health guidelines because she
was with five people
who aren't from her household you know
rules are good for
everybody including the mayor and so my
message today is to say
i apologize for that but i and i do want
us to continue
to follow the rules the rules that will
also allow
2500 fans inside the bell center
for the first time this year to watch
the canadians
take on the maple leafs a small step
towards normalcy
that we all crave mike liquiter global
news
ottawa to that disturbing discovery in
bc
forensics experts will work to identify
the suspected remains of more than 200
children
buried on the site of a former
residential school
indigenous leaders from across the
province have been meeting to decide
what steps to take next global's paul
johnson
is following this story in kamloops bc
tonight paul
robin the next event that we're
expecting here is a community meeting
scheduled for tuesday where the first
nation is expected to share with its
members
more of what they know about this
discovery and the plan
going forward which could very well
entail a massive
excavation effort to identify any
remains that are there
and try and return them to their
communities of origin
the tekamloops first nation says it's
now in the process of reaching out to
bands
and other first nations throughout bc
who have missing children
whose bodies could be in the unmarked
mass grave
they think they found on the property of
the old kamloops residential school
it doesn't surprise me on to kamloops
land nearby
herna garami says the shocking news
squares with stories
she's heard since moving here in the
1970s
there's a child that dies for whatever
reason
and so these were all the same
just put them kind of hid them away
the city of kamloops bc now making
international headlines is the focal
point for canada's history
of forcing first nations children to
attend its residential schools
now understood as a cruel and inhumane
system
for eradicating their language and
culture
two people so far come up to me then
told me about that downtown kamloops is
where we met
alphonse adams as the news was sinking
in
a residential school survivor from the
linton first nation
he remembers playing sports at the
kamloops school
just spend a few minutes with him if you
want to know
how raw these wounds still are the
people that did that
yeah sometimes i cry there
i try to hide my anger
everything else i don't like
crying in front of my children
they don't know exactly what i went
through
one question that a lot of people have
been asking is if we have a situation
here where the
very large number of unexplained deaths
what is the role of law enforcement in
all of this
we're beginning to hear a bit more about
that with both the bc coroner's service
and the rcmp putting out statements
acknowledging
that they've received reports of what
they think might be here
that they expect that they'll be
participating in this but they'll be
following the lead
of the first nation robin a
heartbreaking story paul johnson in
kamloops bc thanks paul
we continue our coverage of a
saskatchewan man convicted of sexual
offenses against minors
who appears to be involved with a sports
camp that has operated for decades
global news has obtained a police report
detailing allegations against the camp
operator that came after the conviction
despite the complaint police in
saskatoon say they didn't have enough
evidence to investigate
and the camp is once again preparing for
its new season
this summer nathaniel dove reports
noelle was 16 when she says her boss
told her she could stay the night
like i'll drive you home or you know we
can just tell your mom that you can stay
here
and you can get up early and work
tomorrow another employee
also accused the boss of misconduct in
his home office
global news has agreed to protect the
identities of the two women
he's like you can't wear your duffel bag
like that that i'm
now i'm looking at your best that makes
me look at your breasts both worked at a
basketball camp
20 years ago for dennis robert hall a
man convicted in 1981
of having sex with two girls between 14
and 16 years old
and indecently assaulting two other
adolescent girls
several media outlets have previously
reported hall received a pardon in 1994.
both employees say they quit and that
hall continued phoning and emailing them
sylvia went to the saskatoon police in
2003. the emails i would receive from
him would say things like
you need help you're you're a sick
little girl like there's something wrong
with you
the police report obtained by global
news states hall
allegedly told her that she should have
a baby and that he could help her with
that
he reached over and rubbed her belly
parts of the report
are censored but it also says there is
nothing at this time that would lead us
to pursue further investigation
or have suspicions that charges may be
able to be laid
i felt even worse when i left
because i felt that it wasn't valid
around this time hall was quoted in a
newspaper article
saying he had changed after his
conviction and he apologized to anyone
who remains hurt
hall did not respond to questions about
the allegations from global news
in a statement saskatoon police said
they couldn't speak to the
investigations
but added they would investigate if they
get more information about the 2003
complaints
or if additional complaints come forward
meanwhile
an email from a camp account to a parent
stated hall hasn't been involved in
years
no one from the camp responded to
global's inquiries but photos on the
website from 2011 to last year
appear to show hall was there this is a
really complicated area
one nick saint-germain is a lawyer for
the canadian center for child protection
she says the federal and provincial
governments need to work together
and that new rules are needed to keep
offenders away from children
we should of course be focusing on
getting people to a place where they can
go back into society and hold a job and
be functioning
but there's nothing that says that a
person needs to be working with children
it's a warning this former camp employee
has issued for years
i think he's a dangerous guy and and he
should not be around children
nathaniel dove global news saskatoon
kingston's royal military college is
canada's west point the training ground
for generations of this country's
military officers
but some describe the rmc as a potential
wellspring of toxic
culture one that has tolerated sexual
misconduct
in the canadian forces now the former
head of training at the rmc is speaking
out
alleging attempts by his superiors to
cover up incidents of sexual misconduct
at the college
erato bureau chief mercedes stevenson
has the story and a look ahead to this
week's edition
of the west block mercedes
robin retired lieutenant colonel mark
popov is a 27-year veteran
of the canadian armed forces he led
troops in combat in afghanistan
but he says his posting to kingston's
royal military college
was more stressful and painful than
command in the violent dan district of
afghanistan during the war
as director of cadets in 2014 and 2015
at rmc
popov was responsible for training the
college's 1
200 officer cadets he says that what he
saw in his time there devastated his
faith in the military
and left him fearing for the future of
the armed forces
popov says two former heads of rmc who
are now
top ranking generals then brigadier
general al meinzinger and his successor
then brigadier general sean friday
failed to take appropriate action in
response to cases of sexual misconduct
documented at rmc under their leadership
meinzinger is now the head of the royal
canadian air force and friday is serving
at u.s central command headquarters
in tampa florida popov says meinzinger
and friday
failed to order folsom investigations
into cases of sexual misconduct
and to punish the alleged perpetrators
popov revealed the global news
disturbing allegations of sexual
harassment sexual misconduct
and a lack of proper care for victims of
sexual assault
popov says he worries about the message
that sent to officer cadets over the
years
a perversion of the rmc motto truth duty
valor
to what popov describes as truth duty
valor
don't get caught this tells the
perpetrators who've gotten away with it
that they can get away with it that they
will be protected that the senior
leadership is not interested in pursuing
it
it enables this kind of conduct
of those who would be perpetrators and
for those who would be victims it says
what you say doesn't matter
because no action will be taken it's all
talk no action both meinzinger and
friday reject popov's claim they failed
to respond properly to sexual misconduct
under their watch at rmc and the
department of national defense is
standing by both generals
in a statement the department said quote
all alleged incidences of sexual
misconduct
were acted upon appropriately and in
accordance with applicable dnd
slash caf policies including immediate
support to any victims
also on the show this week i'll be
speaking with acting chief of the
defense staff
lieutenant general wayne ayer on his
views on rmc
and what comes next for the military in
its efforts to stamp out sexual
misconduct
robin mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes
and you can watch the west block
tomorrow right here on global
coming up americans on the move for
memorial day weekend
desperate for travel that still isn't
normal
it's memorial day weekend in the united
states the unofficial start of summer
and americans are on the move
airports and highways are packed and
that's starkly different from the
holiday weekend last year
more than half of the adult population
in the u.s is fully vaccinated but
health
experts are warning people they still
need to be careful
jennifer johnson explains south
carolina's myrtle beach is packed
as americans welcome in the first
unofficial weekend of summer
the american automobile association
predicts close to 40 million
americans are traveling this memorial
day weekend a 60
increase from last year when cobia 19
had a stranglehold on much of the
country
as more people get vaccinated they're
becoming more comfortable with the idea
of travel but there's still
some travel hesitancy despite higher gas
prices
highways are clogged and many airports
are crowded americans are desperate to
return to normal
it was a long time coming and it is
about time but doctors are warning
people especially
those not immunized to keep their
distance and avoid large gatherings
i am very concerned about people who are
not vaccinated
who think that because the rates are
down they're off the hook
they're wrong they could very well get
sick they could very well
end up in the hospital they could die
the biden administration says it's on
track to getting 70 percent of u.s
adults
fully vaccinated by the july 4th holiday
and some state health officials are
going the extra mile this mobile
vaccination clinic is set up at a new
york beach
bringing the vaccine to people is what's
going to get us to where we need to be
so convenient and too tempting for some
to pass up i said
it must be meant to be let me go get a
shot
u.s airlines which lost 35 billion
dollars in 2020
are celebrating their return to travel
1.5 million passengers are expected to
pass through atlanta
the nation's busiest airport this
weekend the biggest crowd since december
2019.
restaurant owners are also predicting
big business it's going to be crazy
people have been
dying to get out most states have lifted
mask and social distancing requirements
just in time for the holiday weekend
desperate to welcome in patrons and
tourists
and their money jennifer johnson global
news
washington still ahead the new covet
surge in the uk
and the warnings for canada
you're watching global national
[Music]
it was a terrifying scene just minutes
into a ferry trip in indonesia
close to 200 people were on board when
the ferry caught fire
all the passengers and crew were forced
to jump ship
fortunately fishing boats in the area
helped take the survivors to a nearby
remote island all 181 passengers and 14
crew members are
safe but it's still not clear what
started the fire
vietnam says it has detected a new coven
19 variant that's a hybrid of strains
first found in india and britain
scientists discovered it while examining
the genetic makeup of the virus that
recently infected some patients
lab tests suggest this hybrid may spread
more easily by
air than other variants and that it
could be responsible for vietnam's surge
in cases the country initially had
success battling the virus
but in recent weeks it has recorded more
than 3 500
new cases the variant first detected in
india is rapidly spreading across
britain it
is now the dominant strain in the uk the
country has reported its highest level
of infections in almost two months
and as redmond shannon explains there's
concern the variant could delay the
country's
final stage of reopening
[Music]
england is nearly there in three weeks
the last restrictions are set to be
lifted
but the british government says a slow
rise in covet 19 cases again
threatens that goal it's partly down to
the b1
617.2 or india variant
which is believed to be more
transmissible although not necessarily
more deadly the latest estimates are
that more than half
and potentially as many as three
quarters
of all new cases are now of this variant
the new dominance of the variant coming
just after indoor dining and
drinking resumed makes it difficult to
know
what is driving the rise but i want to
stress that
we always did expect to see an increase
in cases that was always going to happen
variant cases are clustered in a few
cities and the highest coveted infection
rates are among
unvaccinated young people last week
there was a week when
one percent of bolton's 10 to 14 year
olds tested positive
i mean that's incredibly high we know
from public health england that attack
rate so the chance of you being affected
if you're a contact from someone with
the indian variant is over 50 higher
than
if it was a contact with the old kent
variant research suggests
a second vaccine dose is crucial against
this variant according to official
figures it currently makes up just a
tiny fraction of cases in canada
i wouldn't be surprised in the months to
come that we definitely start to see a
rise in the b161
7.2 variant if that happens provinces
will be
racing to get not just one but two doses
into canadian arms
but only focusing on canadians will be
short-sighted
according to global public health expert
ananya banerjee
we are on divergence of a vaccine
apartheid
and that we need to make sure at least
10 percent of each country
globally are vaccinated particularly
seniors and healthcare workers
she says unless richer nations ensure
that happens
other variants will appear one of which
might even evade vaccines and
put us all back to square one redmond
shannon global news
london up next virtual healthcare may be
just what the doctor ordered
the pandemic has changed the way we do
many things including how we see a
doctor
consultations over the phone and virtual
visits have become the norm and experts
say
they may be here to stay as jamie
morocco explains
telemedicine could save the medical
industry billions of dollars
just as covid19 began to creep into
canada dr daisy singla launched a
telemedicine-based therapy project
right we're focusing on women who are
pregnant and postpartum
with depressive and anxiety symptoms and
how would you say that
makes you feel currently the system is
being accessed by more than 300 patients
working with 40 providers across north
america
their ability to adapt to delivering
this psychotherapy via telemedicine
has been incredible according to a new
study by uk-based juniper research
teleconsultations are expected to more
than double over the next four years
to an estimated 765 million visits
around the world
in 2025. that trend could save the
health care industry billions
with a virtual visit costing around 39
canadian per patient
compared to over 110 for in-person
meetings
for first-time parents grace poon and
jeff britton prenatal care during the
pandemic doesn't allow for
partners to be present all the pressure
was on her for all these in-person ones
telemedicine pune says has changed that
and is excited to have a virtual option
for when baby arrives
moving around with a baby would actually
be a lot more work
so if it can just be a checkup
i would actually prefer telehealth
but cautions a phone call won't always
cut it point shared by humber river
emergency room chief dr leon rivlin
there are very important conditions like
abdominal pain
chest pain shortness of breath where a
physical examination is absolutely
essential
back at mount sinai dr singlas says
there are still plenty of benefits to
telemedicine
this is an opportunity to improve access
to evidence-based care and with a
retention rate of 90 percent for her
program
she has little doubt this is the future
of canada's health care systems
jamie morocco global news toronto and
that is global national
for this saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is harrison hot
springs
in british columbia we'd love to see
you're part of this country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night